OR I LIKE TO.
CALL VIA ARTS AND ENTERTAINMENT.
TOURS IN THE SPORTS AND TOURISM
COMMITTEE HEARING. AND OLDER AND
WE HAVE ONE ITEM.
AND GO TO SCHOOL WOULD BE QUICK.
AND.
WOULD HAVE THEIR I'VE EVER MOVE
LUCIA EXPRESS A EXTRACT
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO.
BUT THEN SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL.
CHAIRMAN CHIU YOUR.
TO PRESENT WALDRON.
WALDRON PRESENT ACOSTA HERE
ACOSTA PRESENT CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN PRESENT MEDINA. MEDINA
PRESENT LESS AREA.
WE HAVE A QUORUM ALRIGHT GREAT
IT HAVE A PRESENTER DOCTOR CHOI.
PLEASE COME UP.
IN THIS IS FOR PCR Y. FIFTY
SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRMAN CHU AND THE MEMBERS.
AND THE ALL THE.
I SUPPORTING PEOPLE BEHIND ME.
BUT TO BEGIN WITH THE BEFORE I
FORGET THAT I I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT THE I WOULD ACCEPT DE
JA. COMMITTEES.
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS SELF
REGARDING DISTRIBUTION LIST IE
OUT WANTING TO SPECIFY ABOUT
THAT THERE ARE SOME OF THE GOOD
OF THAT BUT MY SO. MINAKO HAD TO
ACCEPT THEM.
AND THE TODAY I'M SO HAPPY OUT
TO UP PERCENT.
TO YOU UP BEFORE THE FLOOR ACR
ONE FIFTY SEVEN WHICH IS A VERY.
MEANING FLORIDA AND OUT THAT
WOULD.
DO SO RESOLUTION ON IS ABOUT TO
OUR ENCOURAGES SUCKS* BORDER.
WINTER OLYMPIC GAMES ARE IN
PYEONGCHANG SOUTH KOREA.
A THIS IS GONNA BE TWENTY FIFTH
OF. A WINDOW OLYMPIC GAMES. AND
THEN ALSO TWELVE SO WINTER
SUCCESSFULLY THIRTY YES AGO OF
THE FIRST TIME IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. AND THE SHOW THE
WORD DOT IS SPECTACULAR OLYMPIC
GAMES.
AND THE MY DAUGHTER ALMOST ARE
ONLY AT THREE MONTHS OLD THE
HOUSE WATCHING MY DEBUT SO THAT
MY WIFE A COULD FUND AND TEAR.
ABOUT A MONTH THE HOUSE NOAH OUT
I HAVE A. VERY STRONG TIES OF
TWO OLYMPIC GAMES.
AND THAT THIS YEAR WHEN NOT
THERE WHEN IT BECAME SO. WE TONI
BECAME CISA A HELLUVA IN MY OWN
HOME COUNTRY. I THOUGHT THAT
THIS WOULD BE A GREAT IDEA OUT
TO.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE TO UP
PERCENT OR. NOT WISH FOR ROUTE.
.
CHEER AND THE US SUCCESSFULLY
ROCK.
THE COMPLETION IS ANTICIPATED
HORSE THAT
LARGEST.
WINTER OLYMPIC GAMES. ARE EVER
SINCE OUR OUR IN THE HISTORY
PARTICIPATING. COUNTRIES SAW.
IN THE HISTORY OF WHEN TONY
BECAME SO. AND THEN ALSO ARE
HAILED AS A SYMBOLIC.
OF FOR THE RECENT TOP PEACE FOR
IRAQ OVERTURE.
MADE THE BETWEEN NORTH. AND THE
SOUTH OF KOREA SOUTH KOREAN
PEOPLE ARE VERY VERY EXCITED
THAT THE MOST KOREA.
HAS DECIDED TO PARTICIPATE AND
THIS MAY LEAD TO. MORE PEACEFUL
RELA RESOLUTION SO I THINK ARE
OUR ATTEND FOR NASA LEGISLATURE.
WISHING SUCCESS FOR LA. ARE
ONLY BECAME SO IT'D BE VERY FOR
YOU A PROPER AND.
ENCOURAGE THEM THIS YACHT ONE
FIFTY SEVEN NO COMMENTS OF SOUTH
KOREA FOR HOSTING IS A TWENTY
THIRD YOU KNOW WITNESSES.
SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME FOR.
AND OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTION FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
NBAMEMES SEEN ON.
I DO HAVE TO QUESTION.
OF PERSONAL FURS THIS WILL WILL
LIST YOUR LAPEL PIN.
OKAY DOT THIS AS SELF FROM COME
CHARM. AND.
I CAN GIVE THIS TO YOU.
TO.
BRING ALL THE MEMBERS OF TWO US
SOUTH KOREA. YOU ANSWER MY
SECOND QUESTION YEAH WE'RE GOING
TO SEE IF YOU CAN.
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE OF THEIR
COMMITTEE MEMBER HAS TO KOREA.
AND AS FULLER
I JUST LAWLER TO I WISH AUDIT.
UNCHARTED YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
I DO MORE COMEDY ONE FELLOW HERE
I'M CHART I IS GOOD. YOU LOCAL
FIRST OFF A.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY I KNOW THIS IS
AN EXCITING TIME FOR CREATES
THEIR SECOND OLYMPICS A.
SETTLEMENT OLYMPICS OF LOS
ANGELES YOU MENTIONED YOUR WIFE.
VOLUNTEERING MY WIFE WAS A
VOLUNTEER IN LOS ANGELES IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. OUT WE HAD
JUST MET.
SO IT WAS EXCRUCIATING FOR ME TO
HAVE HER GONE ALL THE TIME
BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE EARL YOU
KNOW HER EVERY MINUTE LIKE I DO
TODAY.
BUT.
IT IT'S I KNOW I KNOW THAT THAT
FEELING.
AND PRIDE IN A IN A COMMUNITY
IN THE COUNTRY ANYBODY THAT WAS
IN LOS ANGELES AND EIGHTY FOUR.
YOU HAVE TO BE MY AGE I GUESS
TO YOU KNOW HAVE BEEN THERE BUT.
IT IT'S VERY EXCITING IT'S.
IT YOU KNOW TO SEE THE
COMMUNITY COME TOGETHER AND TO
SEE ALL THE ATHLETES COMING
THROUGH THE VILLAGES AND I I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF ATTENDING SOME
OF THE GAMES.
AND IT'S REALLY A THRILL SO
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOUR HOME
COUNTRY. OF SOUTH KOREA AND AND
AND I I WISH THEM WELL AND ON
THEIR. ON THEIR LOOK AT GAMES A
LOOK FORWARD TO TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT AGAIN LOS ANGELES SO WILL
HAVE TO BE THERE.
BREAKING ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT
SHE IS FROM A ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
TWENTY FIVE.
SO WHO WHO VOTE WAS DEAD.
WOULD HAVE THE MOTION AND A
SECOND.
WITHIN THAT SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACR ONE FIVE SEVEN CHOI.
THE MOTION TO BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED AND SENT TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. CHAIRMAN CHIU ARE.
CHAIRMAN CHIU AYE VICE CHAIR
WALDRON. VICE CHAIR WALDRON AYE
ACOSTA ON. ACOSTA AYE DAVID
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I MEDINA. MEDINA AYE MS
AREA. IS AREA AYE TO PASS GREAT
ALL LEAVE TO ROLL HIM FOR THE
ABSENT A MEMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU EMERSON'S
JEFFERSON.
DAVID CHIU.
LEAVING A JORDAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH
.
YEAH.
PHOTO